هل تخطط للتطعيم قبل
يوم التنصيب ، وهل ستفعل ذلك
علنًا بالطريقة التي اقترحها الرئيسان أوباما
بوش وكلينتون أنهما على
استعداد ،
وسأكون سعيدًا للقيام بذلك عندما يقول الدكتور فوسي
أن لدينا
لقاحًا آمنًا  في اللحظة
التي سأقف فيها أمام
الجمهور وأرى هذا المظهر جزءًا مما يجب أن
يحدث ، جيك وأنت تعلم تمامًا كما أفعل ،
فقد الناس الثقة في
قدرة اللقاح على العمل
بالفعل ،
فالأرقام منخفضة بشكل مذهل
حقًا  يهم أين
يفعل الرئيس ونائب الرئيس ولذا أعتقد أن
أسلافي الثلاثة قد وضعوا
النموذج
فيما يتعلق بما يجب فعله قائلين بمجرد
إعلان أنه آمن
، ثم أعتقد أن ما قاله باراك بمجرد أن
يقول فوسي أنه من الواضح أن
هذا هو مقياسي  ثم من الواضح أننا نأخذه
ومن المهم التواصل
مع الأمريكيين
، فمن الآمن القيام بهذا الحديث
عن fouchy
آه هل تحدثت معه ولكن إذا كان الأمر
كذلك ، هل طلبت منه البقاء على
نعم نعم نعم و y  أخبرني عن
المحادثة
قال ما الذي يجب القيام به أكثر من
وجهة نظره حسنًا
انظر آه رئيس أركانتي عمل
معه في أزمة أه الأخيرة
كان يتحدث معه طوال
الوقت رون كلاين تحدثت إليه اليوم
تحدثنا اليوم في الساعة الثالثة صباحًا الذي
قابلته معه ، وطلبت منه
البقاء في نفس الدور الذي كان يؤديه
في الرؤساء العديدين السابقين
، وطلبت منه أن يكون مستشارًا طبيًا
رئيسيًا لي أيضًا
وأن يكون جزءًا من  فريق مرغوب فيه ولذا
ما يجب القيام به
هو أن نوضح
للشعب الأمريكي
أن اللقاح آمن عند
حدوثه عندما يتم تحديد ذلك
ورقم اثنين عليك التأكد
منه لأنه يشير إلى
أنك لست مضطرًا إلى ذلك  أغلق الاقتصاد
كما يتحدث الكثير من الناس
الآن إذا كان لديك في الواقع إرشادات واضحة
وكنت قادرًا على القول بأن العمل على ما
يرام ، على سبيل المثال
الحانات والمطاعم التي ستغلقها ،
سنوفر لك
ما من
شأنه أن لا تفقد عملك كما كنا
ل  مثل المنزل الذي مر
به وسنكون قادرين على إعادة الفتح ،
سنكون قادرين على إعادة الفتح في الوقت
المناسب وعدم الإغلاق
لفترات طويلة تحدثنا فيها عن
إخفاء القناع ، من المهم في الواقع أن نكون
الرئيس و  نائب الرئيس ، لقد
حددنا لك
النمط من خلال ارتداء الكتلة ولكن
بعد ذلك
حيث تتمتع الحكومة الفيدرالية
بالسلطة ، سأصدر
أمرًا دائمًا مفاده أنه في المباني الفيدرالية يجب
أن تكون مقنعًا في وسائل
النقل بين الولايات
في الطائرات والحافلات وما إلى
ذلك ، إنها
مسألة وأعتقد أن ميولي أه جيك في
اليوم الأول الذي تم
تنصيبه فيه لأقول إنني
سأطلب من الجمهور 100 يوم
لإخفاء 100 يوم فقط لإخفاء ليس
للأبد
100 يوم وأعتقد أننا سنرى
انخفاضًا كبيرًا
إذا حدث ذلك مع
التطعيمات
والأقنعة لتقليل الأرقام إلى حد
كبير